[Inaudible].
SARS coronavirus. Two pandemic has helped us all to learn something new.
Some have learned to make homemade bread while others have learned that you can
never have enough toilet paper in your house.
International markets have learned something else that we all depend a lot on
China.
[Inaudible].
World needs masks. China makes them,
but he's been hoarding them as China grappled with the Corona virus.
It kept the masks it made. Now that other nations need them.
Pressure is rising on Beijing to resume exports.
Exactly. After decades of outsourcing production,
we have encountered a shortage of masks in the middle of a pandemic.
So what happened? Well,
the Chinese have been working their socks off in one month.
Comparing in March to April, China was able to multiply its exports.
They doubled the number of respirators and protective suits,
increased mask exports by six times and exports of coronavirus detection kits
were 25 times higher.
We are talking about millions of tons of medical equipment destined for the
international.
[Inaudible].
You're probably wondering what does all this mean? Well,
basically we've become too accustomed to our mates and China products.
Most companies don't even think twice every time they set up a new factory,
China is the preferred choice. So why is this the case? Well,
it's partly because everything's cheaper, but that's not the only reason.
China also offers other advantages as built the necessary infrastructure to
export worldwide.
And anyone who wants to manufacture something new is that if they can find good
suppliers and good manufacturers,
it's in China after years of being the world's favorite factory,
Chinese workers are increasingly better skills.
Imagine you want to build an electronics company.
Your best option is to go to shin. Zen.
It's all there you'll find cheaper labor than United States,
but Shang Zen is also the home of the Wang Wang vine,
which is one of the largest markets for electronic components on the planet.
And I'd like to apologize again,
for my terrible pronunciation of many of the places are going to come up in this
video. So you go to Shenzen and you say, hello, good morning.
I'm looking for this next generation controller boards for the true and I want
to build. And before you know it,
you will find a gentleman who sells boards of that type by the kilos.
You can literally see images online of people going to this flea market to buy
bags of microchips. There are a few places on the planet where you can do that.
So it's already clear. China is made for manufacturing.
Of course, when a pandemic arrives,
you see the drawbacks of relying so much on China.
And hold on just one moment because companies must take into account other risks
beyond pandemics. We're talking about politics too, as we all know,
Trump waged a trade war with China, but make no mistake. Trump.
Isn't the only one who wants to stop doing business with Beijing.
Take a look at Japan.
Japan set aside 243.5 billion yen to help firms shift production.
Out of, as you can see.
In the current environment,
the idea that globalization is a great idea seems to have run its course,
as many feel that China can no longer be trusted and we need to restart
production in several countries again,
but once happy world in which we all jetted around the globe,
holding hands and singing kumbaya and ignoring borders. So today's question is,
do they really see it that way in the corporate world are companies thinking of
leaving China today? We're going to answer these questions,
but first let's take a look at them.
History.
Great. Chinese demand.
First became a buzzword in the 1990s.
And it wasn't always spoken of favorably because those of you who are more or
less my age, and for those of you that are I'm so very sorry.
You're sure to remember the anti-globalization movement,
the organized large protests in Seattle Prague all around the world.
Why were they protesting?
Let's just say it would be easier to tell you why they weren't protesting.
In a nutshell,
let's just say that these protesters thought the globalization served America's
interests for the rest of the world would simply provide raw materials and cheap
labor to be exploited by money.
Nationals.
Localization is itself a code word,
a mask for not using the C-word capitalism.
It is a system at the heart of the system is the United States of America.
The world's only existing empire today to Rigali British Pakistani intellectual.
And this way the United States would get even richer by exporting his products
and culture all around the world.
We would get to a point where people would lose their very identity to an
insidious capitalism and where they used to eat kebabs with globalization,
they would switch to eating. However,
what we have seen in recent years is something very different. So yes,
the United States economy has continued to grow and it has enormous weight in
the world economy, but it's less and less dominant to give you an idea.
In the 1980s, the U S accounted for about 25% of global GDP now,
and 2020, it doesn't even reach 20%.
And this is good news because it means the rest of the world is growing too.
In fact, we could say that the main symbol of globalization is the kebab camp.
This is a typical meal eaten in the Arab world. And when I was born,
I didn't even know what it was. Now.
It's one more dining option along with pizzas, hamburgers, or sushi.
If the Scottish German Doner kebab franchise is not the epitome of
globalization, please tell me what.
[Inaudible].
You are dead brilliant.
The class go from selling 1 million pounds of kebabs a week.
We focus now on the economic realm. What happened? Well, yes, it's true.
The first companies that went into China were attracted by cheap labor,
but for many millions of Chinese,
as more and more companies arrived in the country,
companies have had to compete for workers.
And that means that wages are increasing.
They have risen to such degree that for three years,
we've been seeing news headlines like.
[Inaudible].
In a wage levels equal to or surpass parts of Europe.
Trends that we're seen a long time ago.
Apple closed its last reduction lane in the United States in 2004,
by then most of its product assembly had moved to China. However, by 2013,
they had began manufacture computers in Texas because the higher wages coupled
with higher transportation costs from the Asian country meant China's
competitive advantage over the United States was.
[Inaudible].
Some of you are probably thinking, okay, good.
So wages are increasing in China and at the same time, factories are leaving.
What disaster is development policy?
Not really because what has happened is that China has also become a market.
The goal is no longer to produce goods in China, purely for exports,
but also to sell them a company like Lego has managed to survive the traditional
toy crisis and the competition from the video games industry,
thanks to a seals and the Chinese market.
Everything that'd been lost in the West has been regained in China.
Basically.
Talking about a market of 1.4 billion, Chinese.
We're making more and more money.
They have more and more one to buy our products. And of course,
keeping China as a market is already incentive enough to keep factories in
China, no matter how much workers, which is rice,
because transport costs are also very expensive.
If you have to move tons and tons of your products on a cargo ship,
a transoceanic trip lasting several weeks,
you can imagine that it costs an arm and a leg,
but everything you produce in China can also be sold in China.
You're going to save some logistics.
[Inaudible].
Not reasonable. Lewin has caused a lot of factories to stay there.
The numbers kind of speak for themselves. And 10 years,
China has gone from exporting 17% of its total production to 9% demand in China
has grown so much.
The company setting up a factory in China would already be viable just for
selling its products in China, but that's not the only reason.
And the last 30 years technology has evolved.
A lot machines are getting better and better at performing more and more
functions automatically.
Wait.
It's going to be a revolutionary change for some industries,
automation and artificial intelligence will transform labor intensive
manufacturing and to capital intensive manufacturing.
This means that it will become increasingly attractive for companies to have a
modern factory with state of the art machinery rather than an outdated factory
with many workers.
So the wage factor will no longer be so important and deciding where to set up
your factory. At this point,
maybe will interest a business owner most is to set up several factories of,
for example, toys at a regional level.
I saved the logistics costs and if labor is more expensive in a particular
region, I could also go with automation. I'm no longer.
So interested in cheap labor as I have at my disposal, good infrastructure,
good suppliers, cheap energy, and highly skilled workers to handle.
Scenery.
Visual politic.
We have already talked about 3d printers and additive manufacturing.
Not just anyone can do this. You have to have a specialized training.
So the last few years, ultimately presenters with an emerging trend,
the regionalization of the value chain,
what is produced in Asia is sold in Asia.
What is produced in America is sold in America.
And what is produced in Europe stays in Europe.
And this trend has only accelerated of course,
with the trade war initiated by the United States.
The Trump administration made having a factory in China for are to be sold in
the United States counter-intuitive. And while we were all busy with this,
the event that changed everything. Alright, and yes,
it really has changed everything. Let's take a look at this, right?
[Inaudible].
Does the name a S M L ring a bell and that's not SMR.
That's a different channel of money and I'll be setting up in the future.
It's a Dutch company, but you've probably never heard of in your life,
but it's fundamental in the world.
[Inaudible].
Dominate the market of the most advanced chip manufacturing through the use of
full Tula graphic machines that make integrated circuits.
ASM L's work is with the world-leading jet producers.
The US-based entail South Korean, Samsung and Taiwanese Taiwan, semiconductor.
[Inaudible].
Companies,
all use components manufactured by ASM L to make motherboards motherboards
like those used on your phone or mine. So without knowing it,
you probably have an ASL product very close to you.
And given that this is the case, it's time to consider the butterfly.
[Inaudible].
Just flap of a butterfly's wings in Brazil, set off a tornado in Texas,
Edward Lauren's American mathematician.
Is what chaos theory is all about unpredictability.
So let's imagine the ASMs has to close for some unforeseen reason.
Suddenly smartphone production lanes around the world would start to collapse.
Manufacturers would hold on for as long as their stocks lasted,
but it would soon be a shortage of chips. He's like I'm exaggerating. Well,
something similar actually happened in 2012 and the automotive industry,
a fire broke out in Germany,
a factory and Ivanek Ivanek is the world's leading supplier of an essential
resin for braking systems. And at that time,
the consequences were student felt everyone.
Fire and small German town could curb world car production.
If there's just one concept that we have to get our heads around this year is
that of the value chain, the supply chain.
We're talking about the whole process in which the various companies and
suppliers possibly from several different countries are involved in production
of goods. And as we mentioned earlier, it's true.
That one problem with global supply chains is that we have probably not achieved
100% true globalization when we consider what the terror should really mean.
Because when we say globalization,
we are actually talking about seeing the United States,
Europe and China trade with each other. We could add Japan, the Asian tigers,
Russia, and that's pretty much effortless.
You might want to add some other Asian countries like Malaysia or Indonesia,
but their numbers are still pretty low. India, for example,
is known for having cheap call centers and excellent,
but cost-effective programmers,
but we rarely see anything that says made in India.
The bottom line is that the global supply chain is overly dependent on China on
levels that you cannot even begin to imagine to give you an example.
95% of the ibuprofen consumed by the United States comes from.
Training.
Rhona virus could cause global medicine shortages as China's factory closures
hit supply chains. Needless.
To say,
this dependence on China is problematic because its supply chain becomes very
vulnerable.
Something like Trump's imposition of tariffs on Chinese steel is going to make
many industries fail,
but where the risk has been most visible has certainly been with the Corona
virus overnight.
China was totally quarantined and that meant the temporary closure of a lot of
factories.
Some have struggled because they were used to China's production and logistics.
Know-how their good work allowed foreign manufacturers to work with the just
entertain philosophy to reduce expenses.
Managing a large warehouse is more expensive than receiving the products and
immediately distributed them to the stores just in time seeks to reduce
inventories to a minimum.
The goal is to have the exact amount of products and the right place at the
right time.
And this is why any factory that shuts down for weeks can cause serious supply
chain problems.
But the Corona virus crisis has also served to demonstrate what's companies have
been able to best survive the Chinese lockdown.
And what some companies have tried to do is compensate for the closure by
increasing production in their other factories and countries like Vietnam.
Apple has moved some AirPods pro manufacturing from China to Vietnam.
Thanks to their factories in Vietnam.
Some have continued to produce despite the Chinese lockdown.
So they were able to put one over their competitors and the business world many
have taken note of this and have come to a conclusion, the concept of China,
plus one that is keep your factory in China and produce goods to get the Yuan
from those 1.4 billion Chinese consumers,
but also try to set up somewhere else to protect you from any unforeseen events
Before companies are not leaving China completely.
They are simply diversifying with factories and other locations.
What facts does this have on globalization? Well, let's take a look.
Real globalization. We.
Can sort of say that globalization.
1.0 began when the United States launched the Marshall plan,
Western Europe had been greatly weakened by destruction during world war II,
helping your out of the whole, the United States got a top trading partner.
And so it has continued to this day from Asia would come version 2.0 of
globalization,
which is when Japan and the Asian tigers started filling the global market with
their products. When we were all kids,
everything was made in Taiwan or made in Japan.
But these countries have not only been. Producers are also important consumers,
globalization, 3.0 is what we've seen in recent years.
That shift towards trade with.
[Inaudible].
The moment when China became the factory of the world and has evolved to produce
goods for its own great demand.
The next step in globalization would be to expand into other countries and steps
are already being taken for that such as how Apple has expanded its production
into Vietnam. But stories like that are no longer exceptional, but fashionable.
Look what the Taiwanese company on height, better known by its trade name,
Foxconn the main assembler of the iPhone unintended switch advertisers from its
12 factories.
In China, pawn high.
Expands operations in India, Vietnam amid trade tensions.
Especially it goes beyond trade Wars or the Corona virus.
China is going to play a leading role in this new phase of globalization and
this expansion of globalization to other countries.
There are places that are already becoming China's China.
That is places to which Chinese companies are outsourcing their production.
This will cause China to expand trade ties with countries that will also benefit
from this situation. And yes, we're talking about Vietnam, Cambodia, Laos,
Bangladesh, and the Philippines,
but also other countries far removed from Beijing.
Shane is turning Ethiopia into a giant fast fashion factory.
Not just that Chinese companies are finding new places to set up their factories
or by encouraging companies to appear in other countries,
to which they are selling machinery to boost the production.
China is also finding new markets for firms that have a lot of competition at
home. This is the case with smartphone manufacturers.
Transient.
Biggest phone seller in Africa is a little known Chinese company.
Getting it. This video,
we told you that politicians like Trump or Abbey are pushing companies to leave
China. What is happening is that some may leave,
but everything indicates that the majority are betting on staying in China and
opting for a chain of plus one strategy to reach other markets.
So it seems that the Corona virus may not change things as much as we expected,
true globalization,
regionalization of value chains and the China plus one strategy.
These are the trends that are being seen rather than the end.
[Inaudible].
The question is over to you.
Do you think that this new phase of globalization will see all Africans eating
noodles?
Do you think lots of America's time could be just around the corner and more
importantly, Berger or kebab kebab, leave your answers in the comments below.
We really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos. Also,
if you click the little alarm down there, you'll get an update.
Whenever we release one,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided them the vocals in this episode that were not my dulcet tunes.
Also let's channel as possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely voice, um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider
www.reconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your favorite pocket.
Gotcha.